greetings from the future I come to you
from Super Bowl 100 if you're watching
this congratulations you're still alive
then 2066 is an interesting time to be
alive the Super Bowl is in Las Vegas in
a stadium that pops up like a toaster
strudel from the desert floor
we don't drive cars to the game the cars
drive us they also stop and make us walk
when we have a matter of fitness goals
and trust me you haven't met your
fitness goals you can now print nachos
at your seat no wonder our hoverboard
still can make us hover but our athletes
can they're more magnificent than ever I
know what you're thinking football still
exists in 2066 it does concussions while
better diagnosed and treated haven't
been eliminated neither has capitalism
or hypocrisy no so football indoors the
hometown Las Vegas Centurions are
hosting Barcelona and Super Bowl 100 the
National Football League was once as
international as the International House
of Pancakes the cost-effective
supersonic flight has shrunk in the
world no place on earth is more than
nine hours away as a result American
football isn't quite so American nor
quite so much like football tackling
dummies are intelligent playing surfaces
are spring-loaded and the coach is
literally a voice inside every player's
head back their fans are retinas and on
the low end of the game so scalpers flog
counterfeit contact lenses that you can
also watch the game unfold around you in
three dimensions at home but the cave
dwellers of 2016 called the virtual
reality we modern citizens call reality
the game itself is a classic but I won't
tell you balloons Super Bowl 100
I won't say who gets the trophy from our
commander-in-chief President Robert
Gronkowski but as I say it's an
interesting time to be alive